people been saying that to you oh it was
the first time no me singing it settle
the takeover you ruin that Lauren
sometimes last week at a color la la la
um guys welcome to comic-con have you
been down in the craziness yet no no
you've been in the safe places like the
RET don't worry it's not safe for a long
what is it about this city and comic-con
at this moment it's like it's so
exciting the energy is amazing the
answer is coming come they try to
recreate it in other places but this is
like they can't and people saw the film
yesterday for the first time and people
the reviews are pretty good so how are
you feeling I think they were great it
was a great way to wake up you know it's
it's um it felt really good and it was
the really I think that the part was is
listening to people scream yes when they
were watching the clips yesterday so and
you know the movie doesn't come out to
April so it's it's really fun so you
took some personal joy out of people
being scared out of their minds
absolutely
this is a choice there you know you they
want to be scared so today I say if he's
not my fault yeah we want you to scare
them Yeah right so there's so many big
names here at comic-con Chris Pratt
Nicole Kidman who are you hoping you run
into and do you still like get
starstruck over other stars in the car
today I know right I was digging out on
her when I better on the movie because I
love freaks and geeks
no no just excuse the kids yeah okay
and so were you familiar with this urban
legend oh my gosh that made the year we
were yes yes you knew we were abused by
the legends as we were little kids
okay and you never stopped believing in
the your honor yes so explain the whole
background you go okay la Llorona is a
Mexican folk tale based on a woman who
murdered her children in a fit of rage
over feeling abused by her husband who
left her for a younger woman so she
kills the children who are the most
important things to him and then she
kills herself and and then she's
destined to roam the earth for the rest
of her life in a fit of grief over
trying to replace the her children so
she'll grab any children she could find
so she can't find her own so she trying
to does a second circle is it's a
terrible get scared as a kid your
parents were like watch out no no I mean
he's really our parents tell us the
story our grandparents as well as so
they we behave you know if you don't
behave minor Ana's gonna come get you
you got to come at this time although
your Ana's gonna come get you everything
about it so we believed in it so much
that as an adult you still believe in
and you can ask any 60 70 80 year old
person and we still believe in that
you're not the go to dim the lights
light some candles and say if you don't
behave you don't know okay I didn't want
to let you guys know but before you came
in I did get some candles lit and if you
don't behave in this what are your kids
think did they come to set it all and my
daughter did come and scared it yeah but
it was it fell on Halloween her so I
convinced her that everybody was just
wearing Halloween costumes she still did
not she still it I probably should have
maybe I'm gonna sleep no no but she
doesn't forget anything so yeah yeah my
daughter I didn't bring her I just I was
on FaceTime she says mama you look so
ugly oh my G used lie your honor too
you gotta pass it on it's got a go
generation to generation I mean it is
she hears about it from him yeah but
it's just a story that really I mean we
do even though you grew up as an adult
we still believe in it's all one of
Buddha fear on her remember they make
movies about supernatural occurrences
because they happen yes I tell people
that all the time this exercise it's
okay well you know what listen it's only
my first day here at comic-con so I need
you to slow down anyway um since you are
such a big fan I will ask a Freaks and
Geeks question the documentary came out
what was your reaction what do you think
you know I they did such a good job I
loved it but there was stuff in there
that I had never seen before I mean I
cried watching and I watched I got to
see it a little early and you know you
never know what people are gonna say you
never know if everybody's experiences
after so many years if everybody relaxed
recollects the same things and it was
just they did a really beautiful job
with it what's your favorite memory from
that time on set like when people ask
you about it and you always go back to
one place in your mind oh there's just
there's so much I mean it was a really
incredibly special time I think for most
of us we hadn't done much and some of us
have done nothing yet so it was it was
our it was being introduced to the whole
world of acting and I did I think we all
felt it was special yeah but didn't know
what it would become especially because
we felt like big losers when I got
cancelled so it was really interesting
we did it was really interesting in the
documentary to see how and why and what
that story was cuz although we'd heard
all of that actual people talking about
it was was fascinating and sort of in
the documentary it leaves it open for
reboot because there's sort of this idea
of this high school reunion have you
guys talked about it at all you know we
always get asked and I think you know I
think we all have the same feeling is
just the show sort of exists in its own
special universe now and I don't know
how you recapture that exact
without kind of it'd be really hard to
do I mean if anybody could do it be Jett
and Paul but I don't know I don't know
exactly how they would do it is there a
text chain between like you and Jason
and Seth and busy and like always like
keeping in touch there a lot of us keep
in touch I think there's like you know
everybody's crazy busy so I think
whenever and if anybody runs into each
other it's almost like you're seeing a
cousin that you don't get to see all the
time that you live in a different place
and you know I talk all that's I talked
to busy and I talked to Sarah hanging in
and she's having a baby and her baby
shower you know so it's it's everybody's
life changes a lot and you know we're
all in different places all the time but
I think there's always this works and
sort of family feel to it okay I'm going
to need you to start a text chain and we
need to get this reunion going the
reason people are asking you all the
time is because that's what people want
we love a reboot and we love like to see
you later what's happened you know what
I mean yeah okay but what would have
happened I don't know I don't know
that's why we want to see you that's why
we're asking you have a time leader
Marion star yeah it gets you turns of
different thing for you it's been 20
years since the mummy yes oh how was
your memory of that I do have to in a
system it's funny because years go by
but there are always this projects that
you say and you know in your heart and
they're definitely The Mummy Returns was
one of them and now again it's like
they're in this movie now do you see the
rock and see how his career has exploded
and tonight this was his first real sort
of service all right and I can tell you
that there are many reasons obviously
but I've always believed like just like
Woodling that you know there's just he's
a great actor but officially he's an
extraordinary human being and such a
hard worker he never lets his guard down
and and he's just always out there and
he's always giving giving giving I mean
I have a foundation for the communities
South America and he was right there
helping those in New York he's just a
one-of-a-kind man
Wow so you're not surprised by his
success no I absolutely know not only am
not surprised I celebrated just like
Mendes I love that okay well we're all
getting old old questions Breaking Bad
cast is reuniting yeah so um how cool is
it to see everyone get back together you
know it was such an iconic show and so
it's a great piece of television history
and then just to be part of it was
amazing you know and I was the guy that
just came in and shook everything up you
know but that it's pretty
does it ever surprise you that people
are so interested in things that I'm we
put away no television and film is
forever ya know people that are born
right now that in 10 20 years from now
like oh my god I just discovered this
freaks and geeks show yeah it's crazy
good but that's like the nerve-wracking
part of doing it is it day sometimes it
just never goes away so you're always
nervous about it I hope this is
everything we expect it to be because
it's gonna it's gonna be there for a
long long time okay last thing to wrap
it up I want to know because this is
such a scary film what is the thing that
scares you the most
like for me I'm so scared of the dark
like sometimes I run out of my parents
basement and I'm like why am i running
up the stairs cuz I'm scared of the dark
well I should think Oh everything's
earthquakes okay
have you been in many I have any - yeah
yeah but but yeah okay um spiritually
conscious
I mean like I said they make movies
about this stuff because it's real you
know it's not it's not fantasy and it's
not you know the folly it's it's real
and that's why they base movies on these
things so when you think about it like
oh my god I have an irrational fear of
sharks really yeah I appreciate them I
think they're beautiful creatures but
when I'm in the ocean I always said I
think a little and a little a little bit
of that jaws music in the back of my
money to thank crazy movies yeah I know
you movie stars you're really ruin day
for us out in the world and scary things
amazing what congratulations on the
movie we're so excited to have you and
thanks for stopping by ET and now you're
gonna go take a picture in our fun photo
booth
[Music]